these men used to work for themselves
that was until the Congolese government
moved him and gave the mining contract
to a company from China that means
working for the Chinese if they want to
survive now the hair local authorities
want to pay people to move even further
out to make room for more foreign mining
companies and estimated 10,000 families
could be affected only big companies are
allowed here but we will not leave our
land until we know where they want us to
go is better we also don't know how much
money they are offering us to move more
than half of the world's cobalt is
produced in Democratic Republic of Congo
it's a vital component in batteries used
in goods ranging from electric cars to
phones and laptops but some here in the
southeast township of cthulhu in Katanga
province say they are not benefiting
they want fair compensation before they
move there were two previous relocations
before to the village of Kaimuki 'no
those people are now suffering they were
lied to a both compensation
the government must first build proper
houses for us before we move two years
ago around 600 families were relocated
to this place Kaimuki 'no village about
25 kilometers away from castle oh but
starting over hasn't been easy for
everyone some families say they regret
moving we still don't have proper
sanitation facilities there's no running
water or electricity we haven't had any
politicians come and explain to us
what's going on civil society groups say
pass relocations have exposed corruption
and human rights abuses in the mining
sector the previous relocations did not
work in some cases people were forced to
move the government can't make people
leave an area without providing adequate
housing and other facilities including
fair compensation in a statement the
provincial governor richard mui aged
manga's says with a drop in price of
cobalt on the world market the
relocation of people from Casula is no
longer on the agenda because no company
is ready to finance this relocation
process it is not up to the national
government through the Ministry of Mines
for years locals have been told by the
government that foreign investment
creates jobs but at this foreign owned
mine these men say they earn barely
enough to survive har Mutasa al-jazeera